[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour
today's conversation we're going to be
talking about athlete life
stigma body image and wellness with
victoria garrick
and i'm really excited about this
conversation i've been excited and
looking forward to hosting her for quite
a while just because of who she is the
influence she has and the way that she
really
brings her whole self and talks to in so
many authentic ways in so many spaces
and heads
really i think transformed aspects of
culture especially among athletes
so by way of introduction did want to go
ahead and give you all a feel for who
victoria is
she is a former division one volleyball
player
a ted talk speaker and a mental health
and body image advocate
she was a four-year starter at usc won a
pac-12 championship with her team while
she was there
and impressively finished her career
with the top five's most digs in program
history
i'm in 2017 she also gave a ted talk
entitled the hidden opponent
where she described her battles and
overcoming of depression and anxiety
and that talk itself has been viewed
over 380 000 times so really speaking to
the timeliness of that talk
and her influence she has a really large
social media following which i mentioned
with over 1 million followers across
social media platforms
she has a weekly podcast called realpod
and also started a
pr a non-profit called the hidden
opponent where she
through that foundation has been
traveling around the country really
talking about mental health
conversations
and ways to de-stigmatize and really
increase awareness
so i'm honored thrilled and grateful to
welcome victoria garrett to the atti
hour
thanks so much for being here thanks for
having me i appreciate it
and excited to chat with you today
excellent i'm excited as well and i will
say
i mean i've alluded to this already but
you do have a lot of energy in your
conversation so my job today will be to
keep up with you
in some ways you're actually catching me
on like
i don't know if i would i i don't want
to call it an off day because i don't
want to like label you know
you're going to love all this i've done
so much therapy i'm like i don't want to
label it i don't want to judge it i'm
just going to experience
what's going on but it definitely feels
like
an off day for me i feel like i'm stuck
between
i'm proud of myself and i need to do
more and work harder
so i'm in that limbo right now yeah yeah
i think i really appreciate you just
sharing that honestly too because that's
just
part of the journey i think we're all on
and too many times we're not honest
about that you know when we come on
programs like this we kind of get into
our
performance mode which i imagine i know
for me as you just do i imagine for
someone like you that could be easy to
do
just based on uh being an athlete so
definitely appreciate that that level of
candor and honesty
yeah and i prefer to not be in like
quote-unquote performance mode and i
know what you mean you know it's
if i've had a question asked to me a
hundred times
i just go on autopilot and i give the
answer um
but that doesn't always feel like my
choice you know it always feels like
it's up to the asker or whoever i'm
speaking with like
i don't know what do they want from me
and it's actually made me reflect on
how i interview people as well on my
podcast because
i'll find like some people i'll
interview and i know exactly what story
i want them to tell like i've watched
their players tribune
this or their espn that and i'm like i
want them to just re
reiterate that on my show right and then
i think
gosh are they then sitting there feeling
the way i do sometimes where i'm like
regurgitating a story that i've told
before
so it's my reminder to sit down with
guests and be like
what do you want to talk about today
yeah
that's so important i think and it's a
fine line to walk too because like you
said i mean the fact that you want them
to tell that story
i assume it's because you want that you
want your audience to hear that story
it's going to connect with them but at
the same time you want to be kind of
caring for your guests too to kind of
help them really be their authentic
selves and share in a way that feels
meaningful to them so
definitely yeah definitely a journey
that we're walking on and figuring out
as we go
i mean to be honest i feel like you've
done such a great job of that in so many
different ways
i mean just listening to some of the
conversations that you've held online
and the way that your audience engages
is really reflective of how much they
appreciate
just your level of authenticity thanks
yeah i really feel like that's been
a priority
of mine or like an unwavering
goal is i never want my accounts
to feel preachy
or like know all and i think there are
people who serve that purpose
like i don't know what tony robbins
isn't going to post about having a
hard day he's always going to come with
the like and here's how you handle it
and here's the wisdom and here's
the three steps to whatever and
sometimes i'm just like
hey it's a bad day period i don't
i don't want to fix it today i don't you
know i don't know how and i think that's
given me a lot of flexibility in
what people expect from me and and
lets me use my platforms authentically
because i don't feel pressure to always
have the answer
yeah which is nice because i don't
always have the answer
exactly and i think that's why people
are connecting with you because they can
relate
in that in that space too if someone's
going through that same
place they can feel like okay here well
here's someone that i can
just listen to and engage with through
this medium that knows
kind of can feel where i'm at and really
know what i'm going through because
they're being honest about what they're
going through so i think there's a lot
of
a lot of power in that and then you know
it gives you space as i'm sure you know
kind of
share the victories and the joys and the
challenges along the way and just
i think is really really important for
all of us as a society so
yeah i love it thank you and on that no
i think i also just wanna i mentioned to
you
know before we jumped in just wanted to
kind of check in with you as well
i know you mentioned already this is a
non-off day down on day somewhere in
between
but i mean i'm actually just curious
because i mean i think in so many ways
all of us as a society we're
still going through so much i mean
things are starting to get back to
quote-unquote
normal or this new normal whatever that
is i mean
restaurants are opening up again for me
as an mba fan it's nice to see
people in the stands you know it's a
different level of energy with the games
uh they're going on just you know being
a college professor
you know having students coming back and
things like that but then at the same
time we just hit some grim statistics
because we just hit 600 000 coveted
related deaths in the u.s
we still have all the challenges that
are going on around social injustice
there's still
shootings that are happening all over
the country so it in some ways it feels
i mean just personally disorienting
it's like oh this is excitement but
there's also these challenges there's
also personal things we walk through
so i just i actually just wanted to
start there and see how you're doing in
the midst of all
these mixed things that are happening
societally these days and even in your
own life
yeah it's it's a difficult
balancing act i think some days
i am super tuned in to the darkness
of the world and then other days i'm not
but then the days that i'm not i'm like
i have the privilege to not be floating
in the darkness today and to turn it off
and others don't and so it's
it's tough you know and then at the same
time
everyone you want to validate your own
emotions and your own experiences
but in a time like this how can you not
compare
and have perspective to who has it worse
than you um
or or what could have happened to your
family or your loved ones this year that
didn't or maybe it did
so yeah it's a lot and i think
with my mental health i
like to get to the root of things i like
to uncover you know
why is something triggering for me or
why am i anxious and
i think i've struggled with accepting
that i'm not gonna have an answer every
single day
you know we've been through so much that
this is like a whole new
for lack of a better term like guinea
pig or like this is an experience that
the world hasn't had before like
psychologists haven't seen before
you know we're all figuring out what's
going on why we're not as motivated
or why you know something's happening to
us and so i think today is one of those
days for me where
i'm trying not to judge or label how i
feel but i
definitely feel anxious today and i
definitely
feel like i'm running but i'm not
getting anywhere
yeah how do you feel that makes a lot of
sense i think i'm with you a lot of ways
too i mean one thing that i've shared on
this podcast before is just the way that
the pandemic has
normalized anxiety in a way that we
didn't have before
because of all the unknown and that you
know being kind of a root of some of the
challenges with anxiety we
can't predict what's coming next don't
feel like you have control and just the
fact that we've been going through a
pandemic that we can't predict i think
has leveled the playing field so i think
similar to you i have tried
just in my own life to pay more
attention to what's causing those
feelings
um but even for me personally i would
say sometimes that processing is slow
and it's been slower
in the pandemic so in some ways i'd say
today
it just feels mixed so there are things
i'm trying to be excited about but i'm
also sober at the same time
but then i want to kind of pace myself
do i want to dig
into every single piece of news that's
out there right now about some of the
tragedies that are happening no
do i want to totally ignore them no so
it
in some ways it's just almost kind of
choosing
when i have time to kind of engage in
those but not being oblivious to them at
the same time
um but also some of it i would say is
just giving myself kind of grace along
the way
to say that okay things are going to be
off sometimes i'm not going to be able
to figure out the root cause of it like
i would
normally want to maybe take a pause and
kind of come back to that so i say today
i'm i don't know if i called an on day
i'd say a fine
the day is fine the fact that we're
doing this podcast also helps to be
honest if i'm being honest with my
listeners as well because that's
something that i look forward to
when we're doing these recordings and i
gained so much from just hearing our
guests like you just share
about their experiences and really
encourage others so it's a mixture to be
completely honest it's a mixture of kind
of all those things all together but
this is definitely one of the highlights
i think that
in my own way unintentionally i'm using
these podcasts to kind of elevate my own
mood in some ways on a day-to-day basis
it just gives me hope to be completed
yes
i connect to that too you know having a
deep conversation
can change the trajectory of your day
you know there's certain times i sit
down and i have a conversation and like
i leave it a completely different mood
like so inspired so motivated or
comforted or whatnot and so i'm looking
forward to it as well
um just to be like completely present
and
go wherever our conversation may yeah
yeah i'm 100 with you on that and i
think it really speaks to that
level of community too i mean obviously
community looks very different
these days and it has in the past and
there's all these conversations and
arguments about can you still have that
community by zoomed you have to be in
person
and there's valid pieces to all that but
i think there's still space for kind of
deep authenticity
that doesn't have to always happen in
person i mean people have been doing
that through phone calls through text
and so it really
i think in some ways it's given us
opportunities to really dig into that in
another
way um for me personally not to get too
gentle
i've seen that even throughout kobe that
have family it's spread out all over the
world
so the gatherings we've been able to
have at holidays we wouldn't have had
another time just being able to connect
with people in ways and family members
that we wouldn't have had before
grant it still takes the level of us
being willing to go to that place of
authenticity when we get on
these zoom calls and things like that
but i think there's a tremendous
opportunity there
yeah the weird thing though about zoom
or facetime or whatnot is you feel so
connected and then the minute it's
end or computer shuts you're alone again
in your house or your apartment and that
i think is really weird
um and also there's
an element of i don't know just
sensing someone's aura or their energy
and i miss that you know it's possible
to
have conversations and go deep without
that but
i don't know awkward silences i weirdly
miss those i i miss
feeling tension or or whatnot and that
stuff i'm excited for
as the world opens back up um
but i think it has certainly taught us a
lot about connection
yeah yeah i think that's a great
perspective i mean that you're
highlighting kind of both sides
of the coin too because i've definitely
even sensed that as i've had get
togethers outside with students
you know over the semester it's just a
different level of energy that comes
through and it's almost like
that just that one hour meeting kind of
changed like you said the trajectory of
everyone's day there was just a
different
pep in people's step i know i'm sounding
like i'm 50 years old right now but
that's okay
but you know just what that what that
did to really change people's attitude
during the day just that in person
connection
um it's funny you mentioned the
awkwardness the silent awkwardness
because
those pieces are definitely there too
but even in a way those were energizing
too
so yeah yeah definitely i feel like
learning so much
and there's weirdly
like obviously i don't
wish that the past year like i don't
wish that it happened to our world
but if i'm trying to find a silver
lining and like accept that this did
happen and this is what it is
there are so many things that i think
i've learned
and ways i've grown and i don't know if
i would have had
those realizations or that time or those
family connections or family issues
addressed you know had there not been
such
silence panic and
claustrophobia at one time you know so
so i'm definitely leaving like the
pandemic i literally got a coffee today
without a mask for the first time it was
so weird i felt like
you know that was that was big for me um
i definitely feel like
there's so much i learned throughout
this time
well that's really encouraging for me to
hear too and i think even for our
audience
because in a lot of ways just everything
you've done over the last few years
you've been at such a high level of
sharing your story so openly and
honestly
i think people are getting a lot of that
from you but to even hear that you're
still learning in the process
i think it's just really beneficial for
people to be able to hear as well to
know that
even someone who's had such a journey
and has learned so much there's always
more to learn it's not like this is
not a one-time thing that just ended in
a sense and that's
the story definitely and that's
something that
i have to remind myself of like i had an
instance i gave a keynote virtually
but to the university of wisconsin um on
mental health and body image and these
issues and
um that's a big school for me like
that's a power five
conference school you know i'm it's
wisconsin and then i'm i'm
so the whole few days before and the day
of like i just had such imposter
syndrome i was like
i mean and a whole other conversation is
giving a keynote virtually i mean
yeah it's it's already a lose like you
know no one's showing up to zoom
prepared to
be fully engaged for 45 minutes whereas
maybe when they walk into an auditorium
like you're like okay i'll invest my
emotions i'll open my heart
it's so that's weird and then i'm not
just like presenting a math presentation
i'm like
opening up my heart which is even harder
because i'm like hello is anyone on the
other side of the screen
um you see people fidgeting turning off
their cameras is really difficult
so so that's an element and then i'm i
have that imposter syndrome of like
what if they don't like what i have to
say what if i don't touch someone what
if i don't move them what if i
you know i i lose sight and then i i had
like a last minute therapy session that
day like i happen to
be able to get squeezed in by my
therapist and
um she said to me
but isn't that what you speak about
this right now like why do you feel like
you have to pretend this isn't happening
you know why don't you like open up your
keynote
in your intro with like guess where i
was at one o'clock today
like therapy and so you know i after
they read my introduction
i was like i gotta admit today it feels
really weird to hear my intro
because i cringe at like the
accomplishments and the whatnot because
i still don't feel like good enough that
i i even did things you know
and and then it just really made me feel
lighter continuing with the presentation
because
my big fear that i'm not good enough and
i'm an imposter will guess what i told
everyone
in the first two minutes and i also
think i did gain some respect because
they were like
whoa is this this is tmi from this lady
what else does she have to say
so you know i i think you know going
back to how we even got here in the
first place is
i feel
very okay in not having the answers and
i'm always trying to learn
but i definitely have to remind the
people who follow me of that all the
time
because they do come to me as if i have
the all the answers
or that i'm totally healthy and done
with depression and body image issues
or there's an expectation of like i'm
always happy
i'm always on top of my anxiety and my
sadness and my
and it's just not the case and so i feel
like i'm always saying back
hi i'm i'm definitely i know some stuff
but i'm still as lost as you
yeah yeah i think that goes a long way i
i imagine that folks can really resonate
with that especially when they're
walking through it at the same time
um and it's just it's just good to hear
that yeah not good in the sense that
like oh this is great but good in the
sense that it's
authentic and it empowers other people
too just everything you're going through
so i'm also you know there may be a few
members of our audience who don't know
your
story too so i'd be curious if you could
just share with them especially along
this journey
and and the way that you just even
talked about the impostor syndrome
that's definitely real and so
big at times i've had similar situations
where i've shared
my story as a black neuroscientist with
imposter syndrome
in the zoom setting to you know hundreds
of virtual people i can't see so
definitely
relate to you on that aspect but like
with all of that how did you even get to
this place
of wanting to share your story
especially because it was already hard
and with all those challenges there how
did you move
into the space of saying okay well i'm
going to take this in posture stream i'm
still going to talk about it
what gave you that strength
so just to stop myself from speaking for
the next
hour non-stop i'll give you like the
elevator pitch of my
my story um i essentially
went to usc to play volleyball and on
paper you know that was everything i'd
worked wanted
out of high school you know pac-12 great
team
great school academics like had friends
like this
is what i was supposed to do like i'm a
successful teenager
um but then you know i started to
realize that no matter how many boxes
you check off in life you know you're
that's not the answer to happiness
fulfillment meaning purpose all those
important things that we really need and
i it took me a while to learn that but
my freshman year you know i felt so much
pressure it's like i finally made it to
the club to cloud9
and then it was okay well let's survive
at cloud9 and we were
number one team in the country national
player of the year is on the court with
me
win the first 22 games i'm adjusting to
the college
um academic level i'm always missing
class i'm on planes every other week i
mean
it was just a whole new lifestyle and so
much demand that i was not
prepared for and that i did not know how
to handle
and so as a result i developed
performance anxiety
um intertwined with some binge eating as
coping
um and then going through that for two
years
i didn't oh sorry going for that for
those two things for one year
i didn't number i didn't know what was
happening to me
you know i was like why am i crying
before games why am i so nervous to play
why is my heart racing i didn't even
know performance anxiety was a thing i
thought people had social anxiety i
really didn't understand the scope and i
was like i talk to people i make friends
like i don't
have that so i was like what's happening
to me there was also that
look at me now i'm going off of my hour
rant i'm almost done
i'm like i'm like there's also this
um pressure uh
and this idea of what an athlete is a d1
athlete a usd
you're packed with champions you know
you don't have weakness you get the job
done you don't make excuses you figure
it out
so i also felt really um insecure
and not valid in the anxiety i was
facing in the body image issues
and then come my sophomore year i mean
fell hit that wall and that was
depression for me
and so having gone so that was kind of
how those things
manifested um but then it was my
sophomore year when i
finally was seeing a therapist you know
i really hit that place of like
it's either continue into the darkness
which at this point i'm terrified about
or have that conversation and
wave my white flag and surrender which
is what i thought i was doing at the
time
um and then in getting help and starting
to get better and and getting on meds
and starting to understand
oh this is what's going on this is why
it happened this is how you can make it
better like
this they're you're normal there's
solutions there's there's ways to go
about this
that's when that next element of like
whoa
well then why was i so caught off guard
why wasn't i aware of this why didn't i
know it was okay
and then that's really what sparked my
desire
to share was truly so that
no other athlete had to
go through what i did you know that we
could say something
before it happened um and you know that
confidence
didn't come out of nowhere i uh was a
journalism major i loved storytelling i
loved being in front of cameras
so once i understood and came to terms
with what had happened to me
and accepted it then the normal
personality that i had
kicked in of like well let's talk about
this let's bring attention to it
um so then i delivered that ted talk
which it's a whole another story but it
wasn't as easy as i just made it sound
um and then that from that point on was
really finding my voice
yeah that's great in so many ways i mean
it sounds like there was an awakening in
that sense it's not i mean it sounds
like part of that was
a healthy fear too of where things could
go and that you just decided you didn't
want
to be in that place yeah you know i
think
the thing that i can always come back to
is my young life like as a teenager
i never understood why people would kill
themselves
i didn't get it it was like but life is
so great why wouldn't she want to live
i wouldn't want to be alive and then it
was my sophomore year
i remember thinking to myself
oh now i know now i know why
people don't want to be here and they
don't want to live and
that was my whoa yeah
we are somewhere else now yeah and
you know that was was for me that like
awareness of
okay i'm i've tried to deal with this
myself and it's only gotten worse
um and of course now i'm at a place
where like
yes i have sympathy and so much
compassion and love for those who
are unable to keep living but i don't
feel that way anymore which is why i'm
so passionate about like pulling someone
out of those steps
because i've been in the depths and i'm
out of them and so i want people to know
you can escape
those feelings yeah yeah so important
that realization i think that goes a
long way
you know obviously as we talk about a
lot of times the fact that people are
just trying
to escape the pain because they can't
figure out how to deal with it so i
think the fact that you have that
awareness and can kind of meet people
there and then also that the fact that
you're talking about all the things that
you wish you'd been aware of beforehand
because you just thought things were
normal you didn't know necessarily
what was going on at the time and so the
fact that you're kind of empowering
others to tackle things
head on early on i think it's so
important i'm curious even if you know
if you're willing to elaborate more just
in terms of
you know student athletes who may be
listening in like what is how do you
find that line
between having a high level of
performance and expectation
but then knowing when to pull back
because as i've heard you talk about
lots of times you know as an athlete
there is that fine line of
there is someone else that's ready to
replace you if you kind of slip in your
performance or if there's that
that that window so i mean that's to me
that doesn't sound like an
easy decision to make and i
expect that extends beyond sports as
well i mean people who are in
intense work environments intense
academic settings um even to take the
scope a little bit further i'm thinking
about some of the things we talked about
that this podcast in terms of
minorities who are in situations where
they're the only one there's this huge
weight to kind of represent
kind of a bigger culture than yourself
and all those tensions i'm just curious
you know in your own experience how
how do you how do you suggest that
people kind of figure out that
that line about when you need help yeah
it's a great question i have a few
things i'll share on that
um i will preface this by saying i'll
speak from the perspective
of a competitive student athlete because
that's my experience and i never want to
act like i understood
even the surface of the struggles you
know minority
or someone without white privilege might
be experiencing so
recognize that and don't want to even
act like i could elaborate on answering
that question but to
the experiences of like a
high-performing student-athlete or
high-performing academic student
what i would say is you know the way
that sports culture uh
teaches you to work hard and like the
way they communicate work ethic
is it's the grind it's you always go one
more you always
push harder you do the best don't rest
you know unless this is one of the most
absurd quotes
that used to motivate me unless you puke
faint or die
keep going i mean that is something that
i had on my locker like that is
something athletes use
and it's also praised you know um by
like the goats which i can also
get into later um because kobe bryant
actually has
expressed different thoughts on this you
know things get misconstrued but
um first thing i'd say is the the way
that it's communicated to us
is go go go go go never stop and any
excuses or
pull back is weakness so that's the
first problem is like we're being
taught the wrong thing it's an
impossible standard it doesn't work the
second piece that
i'd actually be curious your thoughts on
this um and i learned this from one of
my
uh favorite sports psychologist dr
michael gervais but
there's a difference between mental
health and mental toughness
and the line often gets very blurry um
and the difference is not communicated
to athletes nor to coaches coaches most
of the time are the ones who ask this
question because
they don't understand like how do i know
when my player is depressed or when he's
just not crying
um or she's just not doing this so
mental
health is obviously like your general
state of mind your general well-being
like let's imagine that is the base if
you think of physical health
ironically it's easy to understand you
know someone physically healthy
then mental toughness is something that
can be trained it's a skill
it's with reps with time with putting
yourself in the trenches with
overcoming adversity time and time again
you get tougher mentally
um however the way they relate to like
peak performance
and being an elite athlete or an elite
performer in any capacity
is you know mental health is the
foundation
um and then mental toughness is the
bridge to
peak performance sustainable peak
performance
so athletes have to understand
you know is am i working at my base
or am i building my bridge right now um
and that's something that i think
each person has to learn for themselves
and they have to be willing to identify
that
to give an example my freshman year
i started and i played but i wasn't in
the position i wanted i was like
in a second string role but not the
first string role
and i remember similar to that mentality
i was like okay when she's in the gym
i'm in the gym
if she's casting i'm passing if she goes
i go like
i will outwork you um and as a result
all of my choices and actions were based
on outworking her
not actually focusing on what was best
for me and so i got anxious i overworked
myself
i wasn't listening to my body listening
to my training
then come my senior year i'm in that
first string position i've done all this
work
and what do you know that girl behind me
she's staying extra
she's doing this and that and i don't
know if it was
you know motivated by me she could have
just been doing it but i i felt that in
me
oh my gosh you know my backup is doing
these things um should i stay
and i was like you know what no i gave
my all for three hours
i feel like i had a good practice and i
think it's more beneficial for me
to call it a day grab my water shower
and go eat dinner with my roommate
because i put my work in i feel good
about that
you know it has to be based on you and
another thing that comes to mind and you
mentioned this in the question was
this idea of like holding back and one
of my favorite quotes from
kobe bryant's um recent novel geese are
never swans
is it takes more strength to hold back
than it does to push
the easy thing is to go one yeah the
easy thing is to go one more
to do what coach says the easy thing is
to buy in
the harder thing is to speak up for
yourself
the harder thing is to say i don't have
this in me i'm working at e-fuel
and i've been there for two days now i
need to rest i need recovery
so lots of points there um
in in an answer to your question i would
invite everyone to explore
are you working with your mental health
is this
an issue of mental toughness and can you
play with that
and use your experiences to help guide
you to when you're making the right call
yeah i think that's so helpful i mean
you cover a lot of ground there i think
it's all
all great especially that distinction
between the toughness versus the mental
health
i mean to expand that a little bit i
mean that's something i think we talk a
lot about
within the field so with me as a basic
neuroscientist and i have some
clinical shadowing that i've done as
well and one of the things that we often
talk about is just
if that baseline has shifted and you
mentioned that when you're talking about
your journey as well so were there
are there days or weeks on end where
people are different than they were
before
they is there has their mood kind of
shifted for long periods of time
even you know on the playing field on
the court etc like has that baseline
really just
adjusted completely where there's not as
much motivation to get up
each day to kind of stay on the grind
versus is it a matter of mental
toughness which is kind of more
of an acute or short-term situational
type of thing
so i think it's really helpful how i've
kind of highlighted those pieces as well
because i think that's part of the
nuance and really if people
if people can sense that the baseline
has shifted like you talked about
that's a whole other scenario than
talking about the mental toughness of
each situation and like you said you can
kind of build and practice that mental
toughness
so i know that's a framework that people
have used as well but just in terms of
when we're talking to just general
population that's often something
that we mentioned just looking for those
differences and kind of overall
demeanor and mood or shift from kind of
what looked
to be people's normal mode beforehand
yeah and i'm curious
your thoughts on this because it's
something i've been
thinking about i don't know if i had
like a concrete
take on it but it's great
that anxiety depression
all these things are being normalized
however
sometimes i wonder if someone
experiences nervousness
and says i have anxiety or experiences
sadness
and says i'm depressed and it's tough
because if someone says they're anxious
or depressed
you don't want to question that you want
to validate that and take their word for
it
that's so important however are we
getting desensitized to what like the
actual mental illnesses are and the what
the concrete diagnosable mental health
issues are
and as a result are some of the people
who are just
nervous or just sad
kind of maybe giving up too soon on the
fact that they could
they could do some work there to to get
back to a place
they want to be i almost think people
are so
um focused on being happy all the time
that the minute an emotion comes that's
not happiness we want to label it
as something that maybe it's not yet
yeah and
i i know that that's like uh
controversial to
say i just think it's an important
component
yeah i think it's a really good question
i mean i'll be a little bit speculative
in that sense as well but i think you're
on to something as well
um so i mean from a clinical standpoint
whenever people are
you know in the clinical situation with
clinical anxiety you know generalized
anxiety disorder
or depression kind of one of the
hallmarks within therapy
is not to avoid the anxiety because that
just lets it sit
so there's you know there's lots of ways
that psychologists kind of walk people
through that to kind of you know you can
do exposure to kind of
walk up to things over time and kind of
deal with it but the reason i bring that
up because i think it ties into what
you're mentioning as well when people
are talking about
times of being anxious or feeling sad
and so there's a line there and this is
a speculative part there's a line to
walk where you don't want people who are
feeling that
to just avoid it because that in itself
is not necessarily healthy because in
some ways you know some aspects of
anxiety
are good for us it kind of helps us gear
up so you know from a
classroom setting people often talk
about you know if you're getting a
little bit anxious about a test that's
probably good it'll probably encourage
you to study and not just
wing it so there's a ramping of it kind
of forcing you to take that seriously or
someone's giving a talk in front of
a hundred thousand people there's
probably gonna be some anxiety but
that's not necessarily
bad it can kind of help them elevate
their performance
you know that can come in with sports
environments as well but i do think
there is a line to walk and i don't know
if i have a clear answer for you
in terms of making sure that people are
empowered to still move through those
things so like you said you have to
validate it you don't want to be
dismissive of it because you don't know
the level of depth that it is but at the
same time you don't want people to be
and maybe this is where you're going
with your question to be hampered by
that or
yeah sometimes i think mental health
issues or mental illness or eating
disorders can become glamorized
and you know you see people wanting to
have that issue and
i don't know like i said i don't have a
it's something i've noticed and i don't
have like a take on it
um i just think it's worth thinking
about
because you know it's important to the
conversation
i agree i think that comes down to some
of the awareness that you talked about
too so that people have a clear sense
of what's just as normal isn't the best
word to use but what's a normal level
anxiety to expect in the situation
versus what is something that's really
much more
severe and so one example i paint
sometimes is in terms of
worry versus anxiety worry is a little
bit more kind of acute in this situation
so someone's worried about a test
they'll kind of be localized to that
experience if they're worried about
their performance with their boss
they'll be localized to that specific
interaction with their boss when it gets
to more anxiety it becomes much more
generalizable
so every time they walk into a classroom
setting if they start to feel
any of those like physical sensations
they're associated with anxiety or
overwhelmed
that's kind of more of a something that
might touch on some of those clinical
pieces so it kind of depends on the
expansion of it
and so i think in some ways it can be
helpful you know when people are
bringing that up to kind of
if people are willing to dive in a
little bit and talk through
what that experience is like i think
that can kind of help people distinguish
and again it kind of depends on how long
it's lasting
and how much different from the norm but
granted i mean i'm saying all that but
there is also
there are challenges with the ways we
diagnose things as well so i have to you
know i have to put that
out and we've talked about that across
cultures as well how were those even
designed and
were they applied to one group versus do
they take into account what different
people experiences in different cultures
so true and like now to flip the switch
and maybe be
the the per the people i'm talking about
is with eating disorders
there's such a specific
clinical threshold that you need to
like uh meet to have that diagnosis
and you know i and so there's that
that's one example specific example and
then there's obviously something sad
i've been learning is like not every
professional
licensed professional is is necessarily
on their game like necessarily knows
what they're talking about which is
crazy like how can someone be
a licensed mental health professional
and and not
be like not be not necessarily good at
what they're doing but miss things or
over diagnosis
you know what not so you're right
there's totally a
uh a flaw in the system there as well as
people might not be getting the
diagnosis
that that they need or that's right for
them um
and i certainly felt that way with uh
my eating disorder because i know i had
a binge eating disorder i would not call
what happened to me
less than that but if i look up the
wrong site
or the wrong that's that there's like
one thing i don't meet
you know and of course i had a uh one of
our dietitians at sc
you know when we met she was the one
that like diagnosed and confirmed this
for me but i always still felt a little
insecure about it but i've come into my
own of like no i know this
is what was wrong with me and so then
once again there's there's that other
side of the conversation is
people know what they're going through
and it's always hard to get maybe an
external person to validate that and
fully understand what their needs may be
yeah i think that's really important i
think one thing that can be helpful
there well a couple things actually
i mean you're right unfortunately in the
sense that not everyone is on their
a-game
when it comes to just dealing with
mental health and so there
unfortunately has to be some level of
discernment
on people who are looking for help which
is unfortunate because it's backwards it
shouldn't be that way
but sometimes it might mean going
through two or three people until you
find the right match
and again just knowing people you know
just figuring out if people
are doing things appropriately that's a
lot of and again there's a lot of
unnecessary weight on the person who's
looking
right that we often say is like are
people actually willing to listen to
your story
when you come in because you are the
expert on your life and you're sharing
that with someone are they listening to
your story and trying to figure out
where you're at
or are they just taking a specific thing
and kind of dumping that
on you a specific diagnosis or specific
framework
and dumping that on you which again gets
the thing that you talked about before
of
are they aware or or constant or
equipped
to really deal with the the binge eating
disorder if it's there and we talked
about that again i know i keep
kind of harping back to the theme of the
podcast but we've talked a lot about
just cultural competencies
competency too if people are able to
think about where different people come
from i think this extends even you know
the things athletes may be going through
people from different cultures and
listening to those stories or kind of
just dumping a specific diagnosis
on people so i think when there are
those who kind of have that balance
of their expertise and listening to
where people are coming from i think it
goes a long way
yeah that's all fascinating
are there ways that because there's i
mean there's so many good things that
we're pulling out here this would
probably be a three-hour conversation
but
are there ways that you've tried to even
incorporate some of these concepts
in your talks or online in your podcasts
on youtube to really
empower people because i mean the
questions that you're wrestling through
the questions that we're talking through
i think people can clearly tell from the
conversation even we don't have all the
answers
so how do you take that and try to help
other people even get to a place of
knowing where to start
i think i've had to get clear on
what my purpose is and what value i can
bring
and you know i'm not
a psychologist and so i'm not going to
be hosting one-on-one sessions with
athletes
acting like i can solve their problems
because i can't
but i think what my value-add is
is de-stigmatizing the issue for people
who are
in similar highly touted
role position like like i was so i think
there's that element i think there's
normalizing the many concerns
and challenges and insecurities
and struggles that people in those
situations are facing as well
um i think it's also relating and being
able to
speak on that level of like i'm a
teammate
or i'm like a friend you know oftentimes
when i come in to speak
there's just a totally different
connection because i
it's almost like street cred it's like
i've i've been in their shoes
exactly like i i know what they're going
through
where sometimes when someone tries to
relate to you and they they don't get it
it's just i i often have we'll have
literally like the sports psychologist
at the school be like
gosh like they're listening to you but
say the same thing i've
said but only because you're like the
same age as them and you played it
like you get it because when it's coming
from an adult or someone who's not
close so so i think that's also
something unique is it's one thing for
the
for even i mean a school is lucky to
have an athletic director address mental
health but if someone in that position
addresses it
it still won't hit the same as a peer
and i consider myself a peer and i think
that's one of my superpowers and
in that sense for this conversation yeah
i agree with you on that
what are some of the pieces that you try
because even as you're talking to other
student athletes or coaches are there
specific tips that you have for folks in
terms of like what to look out for
um because one of the things i've often
wondered you know as you were going
through everything did you think your
teammates and friends did they notice
anything
were there things that they could have
said that would have been helpful
and if so are the things you try and
pass along to others
yeah you know i would say um
talking so if i'm sharing my story or
or speaking or giving takeaways or
whatever it is i think most of the time
with athletes
i like them to know
that their their journey and their
trajectory while the details might be
different than mine
like hey i get it and this is how it
happened to me and how it might have
happened to you and
and you're not alone in that and i think
with coaches it's more
this is the experience or this
is how like the epitome of your number
one ideal recruit like the epitome of
that for you
how they went off the rails or how they
didn't become successful or how they
struggled or suffered in some way
because i like to think when i walked on
usc's campus
i was everything a coach would want um
not from like and i'm not speaking about
talent
i'm speaking about like coachability i
was eager to be there i was a good
teammate i was energetic i was positive
i was enthusiastic like all the
intangibles you would want in a player
like i really
would back myself up and i walked onto
campus with those
how does that athlete become depressed
how does that athlete become anxious and
not want to play anymore
and so that's the journey i try to take
those coaches on
because they sit in their office and
they don't know how that happened
or they say like we know you guys are
stressed but no one's actually really
said
yeah and like this is why we have the 6
a.m this 7 a.m not 8 a.m
and then i get home at seven i got to
watch film on the night 6 a.m again like
no one's really you know that's other
thing from the coaches perspective is
i get to say what the players afraid to
say and that
that's the value add there is like your
players are thinking this and i'm
i don't care you can't bench me so i'm
going to explain
you know what's going on yeah i think
that's so powerful
i mean you're giving that voice i think
that goes such a long way and
it's actually wraps back into the point
you made earlier too about just
everything
with it with covet i feel like and i
could be wrong but there is
at least from a coaching standpoint it
seems like there has been a little bit
more
awareness of that again i'm talking from
the outside as a non-college athlete
but just things i've seen i even
remember you know i'm a duke right and
think about coach k
giving the team a couple weeks off
instead of playing games because he said
he was
concerned for his players mental health
and just giving them a space um so grant
this is from the outside but i don't
ever remember hearing any of those
conversations
beforehand maybe more so has kind of
been the backlash so i think it's great
that you're there
in a way infiltrating is not the right
word but in a sense i mean you're on the
ground
having those conversations making sure
it gets hurt and hopefully
in a way that penetrates that people are
able to kind of receive and incorporate
right and i think that's talking about
you know the benefits from
what's happened is the awareness and the
inability to deny the legitimacy of
mental health issues
um for so many different groups of
people
so it's i think that's been a
one of the you know positives which is
still so hard to say
of all of this is like you can't ignore
mental health anymore you know the
crisis is real it was real it's
even worse now and we can't just ignore
it
yeah yeah i think that's so important
hopefully that feels uh
encouraging and validating the work that
you've been doing for years already i
mean i know that what you're doing is so
impactful
for so many people and just even some of
the videos that you've you've put online
the ways that people respond to your
work i know it goes
a long way and i assume it's spreading
too like each person that you touch is
able to kind of share that with others
around around them as well so definitely
appreciate the work that you're doing i
feel like the time went really quickly
we could probably go on for quite a
while
of any last words of uh advice or
wisdom that you want to share with the
audience in terms of just the general
audience and student athletes in
particular
yeah well first of all thanks for having
me i agree it flew by was great speaking
with you
i just love to encourage you know any
student athletes who are maybe
looking for that community or looking
for a place to have their story heard or
for support
can definitely check out the hidden
opponent which is the nonprofit i
founded
we have a really cool private facebook
group with over a thousand athletes
um cool free events you know just a
place where
if you want to connect with other
athletes who are having these
conversations
and and feel supported to definitely
check that out and that's just the
hidden opponent.com or the hidden
opponent on instagram
excellent we'll definitely appreciate
you sharing that and again appreciate
the work that you're doing to
really help so many folks and empower
and help people kind of be
uh whole in that sense and really make
sure that
mental health is at the forefront and of
course thanks for jumping on the addi
hour appreciate having you here
thank you